[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com just days after the FCC's net
neutrality repeal was enacted which was
on Monday CNN is reporting that a TN
t--'s buyout of Time Warner which owns
CNN has been approved by a judge and
we're descending even further into what
I'm calling media consolidation dystopia
and I first reported to you who knows
when I mean late 2016 that AT&T made a
deal to buy Time Warner for 85 billion
dollars some people are calling it a
merger it's really a buyout but
effectively it is the coming together of
these two companies I think it's okay to
call it a merger even though legally
speaking that's not what it is I told
you that this deal would be disaster for
consumers okay it would be bad for
competition it would raise prices it
would reduce choice and I told you at
the time that there should be legal
challenges to that merger or buy out and
there were including from the Trump
administration although possibly for
personally vindictive reasons rather
than questions of antitrust but a judge
yesterday has ruled in favor of the
buyout AT&T now says they're gonna close
the deal out by June 20th this is days
away the judge even said don't bother
bother with Appeals because appeals
would be unjust in this particular case
and we know that Donald Trump has had
been at least sort of nominally opposed
to the buyout but it's mostly because
the guy doesn't like CNN and Time Warner
is owned by CNN but nevertheless it's
happening despite Trump's wishes despite
my wishes and a lot of other people's
wishes this is going to happen and
content that is produced by Netflix and
Amazon which for all the criticisms that
we can have about Netflix and Amazon
Netflix and Amazon were causing
cord-cutting people canceling cable
right that was putting some competitive
pressure
on the big cable providers Netflix and
Amazon are now going to be potentially
hurt by this buyout AT&T could if they
wanted give their own content right like
Time Warner content soon to be priority
and then charge more to Netflix or to
Netflix users to use their bandwidth you
want to pay more for Netflix or do you
want to watch Time Warner content and
lots of people will say I'm already
getting gouged by AT&T I'm not gonna pay
even more to be able to watch Netflix
content without constant rebuffering I
don't know you could say I'll cancel my
cable and just buy internet from AT&T
well then your internet becomes much
more expensive because you no longer
have a bundled package and it's still
Netflix com that could be slowed down or
deprioritize so good luck with that and
we have in the last I guess 72 hours the
inaction of the net neutrality repeal
and even more media consolidation
consumers are going to have a very bad
time and I wonder and I'm not asking
this rhetorically I genuinely wonder
what is CNN's coverage of net neutrality
going to look like after this buyout
then I remembered oh right they barely
covered it to begin with so I guess
that's not going to change much we're
still not gonna hear a damn thing about
net neutrality from CNN or Time Warner
or AT&T and this is only going to
continue this is a signal if you are
Comcast which is potentially going to be
buying part of Fox or Disney which also
wants to buy part of Fox or is trying to
already if you see this decision from
the judge and you see the direction that
this is going it's a green light for
even further consolidation and we've
been tracking and participating in the
rise of independent media for years
right we are an independent media
program we've been covering independent
media and there are two forces which
could completely decimate our industry
it's not even really an industry it's
more of a niche number one getting rid
of net neutrality just happened right
decided months ago enacted on Monday and
more media consolidation happening and
more is coming and if you want just like
a little hint as to how the future of
these mega mergers is going to go look
at the fact that the judge in this case
imposed no additional conditions on AT&T
buying time warner the judge just said
sounds good to me and don't even bother
appealing so this is it I don't know
what else to call it
then a Red Alert dystopia yeah it's
really bad and maybe et and Time Warner
don't have a monopoly on the industry
but telecommunications is so big of an
industry and impacts so many people in
so many different ways you may get your
news through it you may connect with
people on it may get entertained by it
and so it's really upsetting that you
know fewer and fewer voices are gonna be
heard from all of us I think you know
Comcast owns what is it NBC and then
Viacom and CBS maybe getting together to
I think we're gonna see a lot more of
this it is the exact sort of cautionary
tale that for about 25 years really I
mean at least 22 years since the 1996
Telecommunications Act but really 25 or
even 30 years Media serious media
analysts and academics have been warning
about and it's happening your media will
become more expensive you will have to
work harder to find alternative media
the distributors of media as Pat is
pointing out are increasingly going to
be the producers of media as well and if
you're if you're hoping that now I get
to Pat silver linings that people
sometimes hear or me telling you what to
do to fix this
I don't know right I mean I'd say
contact your representatives except
they're mostly okay with this stuff
Democrats did vote for net neutrality
but really all of them part complicit in
the status quo that's being perpetuated
vote them out then right I don't know
what else to say yeah it's a call to
action to support the shows that you
like the specific websites you like and
you know maybe supporting independent
media shows like ours very nice I like
that Pat clip pat's now getting in on
the indirect references to membership in
patreon but seriously I actually don't
have good news I like to try to wrap up
the story with some at least cautiously
optimistic something and I don't have it
because it's really really getting bad
just one day
for calling kim jeong-hoon smart funny
and a great person Donald Trump is so
upset with Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau that he's now going to be
punishing the people of Canada Trump was
interviewed by George Stephanopoulos in
the this was the same interview we'll
talk about later where Trump ascribed to
himself one of the greatest human
memories of all time which was why he
didn't need to take any notes during
that meeting with Kim jong-un
during the same interview Trump said
that he is just so displeased with
Justin Trudeau's recent press conference
that he is going to make it cost a lot
of money for the people of Canada he
learned you can't do that you can't do
that said Trump speaking about Justin
Trudeau we have simultaneously direct
threats to the people of one of our
great allies Canada and compliments all
around for a brutal dictator Kim jong-un
who has his own family members murdered
in cold blood what does this do for the
prospects of renegotiating NAFTA which
Trump has campaigned on it's not gonna
help what does this do for Trump
standing for Trump sort of position
within the g7 which was already pretty
touch-and-go doesn't help and it's not
even totally clear what set Trump off
about the Trudeau press conference
Trudeau has been critical of the steel
and aluminum tariffs he said that Canada
isn't going to be pushed around by Trump
but that's not an insult right it's it's
just saying we are a country and we can
make decisions and we're not going to be
pushed around it's notable only if the
assumption is Trump should be expected
to be allowed to push anybody who he
wants to push around around and I was
talking to some Canadian friends who
said yeah listen I don't agree with what
is being said by Donald Trump here but
this is great for Justin Trudeau and I
looked into the approval ratings for
Trudeau and as of just a couple of
months ago Justin Trudeau's party had
only a 44% approval which for Trump
would be a record high but for Trudeau
is actually quite low and Trump
attacking Trudeau and threatening
Canadians is actually a gift to
Trudeau's reelection chances and I don't
know if that's
they welcomed by Trudeau or now I don't
know if he's aware of it but he has now
set up Justin Trudeau to not give an
inch on trade deals and to have
Canadians still support him and doing it
right if Trump hadn't attacked Trudeau
and the Canadian people Trudeau would
actually take some flak for resisting
renegotiating a trade deal or signing a
trade deal or whatever Canadians now are
gonna stand behind the guy even if in
the short term he makes decisions that
might not be the best decisions for
Canada Canadians are going to be
increasingly willing to say you know
what Trump went after him Trump went
after us and we stand behind Justin
Trudeau holding firm here because we
don't want him to be pushed around I
don't know what the future is of
Canadian US relations but what I do know
is that the contrast between how Trump
is treating Kim jong-un and treating
Justin Trudeau is unimaginable would
have been unimaginable a year ago two to
three years ago and I think that this is
probably a good thing for Trudeau yeah
my sense is that this will certainly
backfire on Trump because Canadians seem
a lot more liberal than us here in the
United States and what Trump is really
saying is that Trudeau doesn't care
about his own people so much because
he's going to let them be victims of a
trade war sure contrast that to what he
said about Kim jong-un at the summit
which is that Kim loves his own people
you can't really make that argument when
the guy has gulags his killing his own
people the guy who's killing his own
family members
forcing famine and starvation upon his
own people and running one of the most
brutal totalitarian regimes according to
trump loves his people but Justin
Trudeau apparently is indifferent to the
Canadian people because he quote
insulted Trump
I guess merely by saying he's not going
to be pushed around this is a new era of
American diplomacy even though you can't
really call it that and geopolitics and
consider once again right this is what I
keep going back to the contrast between
our relationship with Canada and North
Korea Canada has teams in our sports
leagues North Korea sent otto warmbier
back to us in a coma
and Trump is friendlier over the last
week with Kim jong-un than he is with
Justin Trudeau Trudeau might actually
get more respect from Trump if he
decided to start developing nukes
forcing starvation upon the Canadian
people and having his uncle murdered or
something like that because that's what
Kim jong-un has done and it's getting
compliments for Trump it is the era of
the United States of America embracing
North Korea and Russia and Turkey
while seemingly deliberately ruining our
relationships with the European Union
and Canada and Mexico I guess this is
what they meant by Trump would be an
unconventional president or something is
that what we can say yeah it just seems
like he's taking all these positive
relationships with Canada with it you
for granted which you can never do right
you can never lay off the gas I think
Trump aswer argue though that you have
to keep your friends close and your
enemies closer that's apparently what
he's doing now they would argue that now
because it can be used to defend what
Trump is doing they would not have
argued that under Obama or under
Democratic presidents that's for sure
send me your thoughts and my question is
and this is not a rhetorical question
what the hell is going on that's my
question I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and I look forward to hearing from you
with with some analysis to how to
interpret what we're seeing at this time
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the
day's Barbara bails Barbara thank you I
really appreciate you being a david
pakman show member and getting all of
those great member benefits including
the world-famous bonus show but it is
not just new members that I want to
thank I also want to say thanks to Bryan
Wintermute who has been a member since
2012 today's long term sustaining member
of the day join Barbara and Bryan by
signing up at WWE
40% off coupon code available vote soon
18 all right it's time let's get into
this week's hatred mail so what if the
president's been accused of sexual
harassment 15 times or that he paid hush
money to a porn star
at least he never wore a tan suit
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom so last week hatred mail
coined a new phrase that I really like
which is ad Homme of him instead of ad
hominem it's an ad hominem this week
there's another new phrase coined by
hatred mail but it makes no sense the
phrase is anti facets it's opportune and
if that doesn't make any sense to you it
certainly doesn't make any sense to me
let's take a listen David Pakman I had
sex with your wife you cook I am
clicking not interested in the David
Pakman show don't want to listen to this
pc vindictive ex show anymore a news
radio station David Pakman and a wife
whose bidders ass is also clearly greedy
didn't you have concerns David hmm
auntie Fosse to eat supper tuned exactly
right auntie facet sits off poor tune
and
a good its opportune to you Pat it's
good to have you back on the program is
yeah is that like a prescription
medication name I'd have no idea what
that is I I think I actually saw a
commercial for talking to your doctor
about anti facets it's opportune on late
late night television last night here's
one phrase that I know the meaning of
precisely and it's hey tree at 40 that's
the coupon code that'll save you forty
percent off of a david pakman show
membership and every time you sign up
for membership using the coupon code hey
tree at forty thirteen hey tree it's
shed it's here and I think that that's
something we can all be very very glad
about it is starting to get stunningly
stupid with the earth Korea situation
that the United States finds itself in I
mentioned yesterday after the summit
that Donald Trump clearly thinks that he
is won and his followers have been
tricked into thinking the exact same
thing and as I pointed out yesterday the
so-called deal that was made is almost
identical to many past deals where North
Korea has agreed in principle to
denuclearization and to seek peace or
whatever else but most importantly
nothing was actually done and most
importantly in this negotiation nothing
has actually taken place so far we have
a very vague and non-committal single
piece of paper signed by Donald Trump
and Kim jong-eun Trump has said that
he's stopping military exercises near
North Korea North Korea hasn't yet
proven that it's going to do any of the
things that Kim jong-un signed off that
he would be doing and what is absolutely
stunning is that in the last twelve or
so hours North Korea's state media
agency KCNA is now claiming that Donald
Trump has agreed to lift all sanctions
on North Korea is this true Trump didn't
mention it it's possible that KCNA is
lying but at the same time Donald Trump
did say in this bizarre press conference
after the summit that after they signed
the piece of paper there were a bunch of
toss ins both Kim jong-un and Donald
Trump mentioned a bunch of extra stuff
of course only verbally not in writing
anywhere that they were going to be
doing so has Trump agreed to lift sank
on North Korea in exchange for nothing
actually being done yet White House
hasn't commented at least as of a couple
of hours ago but if indeed Trump did
lift sanctions on North Korea it's
another one of these examples of Trump
doing something in exchange for nothing
because North Korea hasn't done anything
yet and there are trumpets who will hear
me and they'll write in and they saw
David I thought you were against war and
against conflict why don't you want to
get along with North Korea and I do want
to get along with North Korea but North
Korea is a brutal regime with forced
starvation
political killings totalitarian control
and no master negotiator which Donald
Trump claims to be should start just
giving concessions away like candy
before you either get something back or
at least get an assurance something
binding that you're going to get
something back and this dangerous
blindness to reality is particularly
evident in Donald Trump's recent tweets
this morning Donald Trump took to
Twitter I guess as he was arriving back
from Singapore saying first quote before
taking office people were assuming that
we were going to war with North Korea
President Obama said that North Korea
was our biggest and most dangerous
problem no longer sleep well tonight
then also tweeting just landed a long
trip but everybody can now feel much
safer than the day I took office there
is no longer a nuclear threat from North
Korea meeting with Kim jong-un was an
interesting and very positive experience
north Korea has great potential for the
future the degree of nuclear threat from
North Korea hasn't changed from 48 hours
ago because nobody has done anything yet
Kim jong-un has made vague non-binding
sort of commitments to start making
changes at some point in the future the
idea that Donald Trump would come back
and remember we are now in a world where
his statements on Twitter are to some
degree official statements that they
communicate what the president truly
believes is going on the idea that Trump
thinks the nuclear threat
North Korea has been eliminated is
stunningly ignorant and dangerous he
signed a piece of paper agreeing to
things that North Korea has previously
agreed to do and then for subsequently
ignored and Trump is literally tweeting
no more nuclear threat from North Korea
on the off chance that this doesn't work
out Trump in apparently some kind of
exhaustion delirium from being awake
more than 24 hours told the truth
yesterday before leaving Singapore and
Trump said listen you know what if Kim
jong-un doesn't stick to what he said he
was going to do I'll come up with some
excuse as to why it's not my fault
anyway bizarre video of Trump being
strangely honest after the summit take a
look I think he's I think honestly I
think he's gonna do these things I may
be wrong I mean I may stand before you
in six months and say hey I was wrong I
don't know that I'll ever admit that but
I'll find just I'll find some kind of an
excuse okay one or two one more come on
Trump's joking about it but that's
actually exactly what he will do right
it's it's it's brilliant in its evil
genius he has claimed victory including
on Twitter saying nuclear threat from
North Korea is over we did it we won
North Korea is no longer a problem and
he's doing this by accepting at face
value the sort of statements that
previously have been immediately ignored
by North Korean leaders and he
straight-up told us he said in public in
front of a camera if it doesn't work out
in six months or whatever he won't admit
that he's wrong he'll just come up with
some excuse for right why it wasn't his
fault anyway in his exhaustion he made a
joke that is actually what he will do
but then the midterms might be over and
he might be well on his way to
re-election by that time yeah maybe a
misstep I think I found the lien I think
that this is exactly because his
supporters don't care right they'll
forget about this and in six months
Trump will say I did my part I made
every effort I got the commitments I
wanted to get who could have predicted X
Y or Z which led to Kim jong-un
ultimately not doing it it sounds like
wishful thinking on both sides right
North Korea is saying that the u.s. is
going to pull all of its sanctions the
u.s. is saying that North Korea is going
to denuclearize
really probably I mean probably not none
of those things are gonna happen but it
allows both sides to claim victory and
that's what they want they didn't want
this to be a waste of time and that
that's the priority for Kim jong-un
right he wants to win the propaganda war
both internationally but importantly
within his own country and I mean
serious question if you're Iran right
and you see this happening even if we
don't know exactly which of these claims
are true and which of these claims
aren't true
what do you start doing if you are Iran
because if it's true that Trump is
lifting sanctions on North Korea and
he's going to help them build luxury
hotels and bring great amounts of
business and tourism dollars or whatever
if you see Trump doing that with one of
the most brutal and oppressive regimes
in the world while trying to impose
tariffs on our allies what do you do if
you are a country like for example Iran
not a rhetorical question that's a real
question I have I don't really know how
to introduce this next story to you
North Korea is known for producing
propaganda videos and the hallmarks of
these videos are total delusions of
grandeur with regard to Kim jong-un
portraying him as almost like a god-like
unquestionable hero narcissism
narratives that make no sense a really
ostentatious tone and we learned that
right before Donald Trump and Kim
jong-un walked into the room for the
Singapore summit one of these propaganda
type videos was played and in the room
initially people believed that this was
a North Korean video that the music and
the content everything seemed like North
Korean propaganda portraying Pyongyang
as some kind of amazing cosmopolitan
paradise it was later learned that this
was a White House produced video the
White House produced and played a video
that was indistinguishable from North
Korean propaganda right before the
summit take a look at some of it seven
billion people inhabit planet Earth
of those alive today only a small number
will leave a lasting impact and only the
very few will make decisions or take
actions that renew their homeland and
change the course of history history may
appear to repeat itself for generations
cycles that never seemed to end there
have been times of relative peace and
times of great tension while this cycle
repeats the light of prosperity and
innovation has burned bright for most of
the world history is always evolving and
there comes a time when only a few are
called upon to make a difference but the
question is what difference will the few
make the past doesn't have to be the
future out of the darkness can come the
light and the light of hope can burn
right what if
of people that share a common and rich
heritage can find a common future their
story is well known but what will be
their sequel yeah so it's an
embarrassment beyond words that the
white house would produce such a video
period but it is especially embarrassing
that it portrays North Korea in this way
right it's portraying North Korea as
this just idyllic place kids are
skipping through Pyongyang Kim jong-un
is waving to crowds of adoring people it
is White House produced propaganda in
the style of North Korea and then
putting all doubt to rest last night
Trump himself actually shared it on
Twitter saying here is the video a story
of opportunity that I shared with Kim
jong-un at the Singapore summit there is
one possible defense of this which I've
already heard from trumpets and that
defense is David Trump knows that this
is propaganda the White House knows that
this is propaganda this is just to
butter up Kim jong-un to get him to make
commitments that we want him to make if
that's the case it failed because Kim
Jong hoon committed to nothing and made
only the same sort of vague statements
of support for unenforceable future
denuclearization can you believe that
this is now what the White House is
producing I mean P it was interpreted as
North Korean propaganda and it was an
official White House video yeah I mean
but what else could they possibly be
doing though in that White House I guess
there's nothing else to fill that time
that they have day to day I guess maybe
somebody there actually thought like
this this makes sense right let's couch
this entire thing as an historic event
and they are certainly saying that that
it was in an ubiquitously positive way I
agree that this is historic in the sense
that most presidents have understood the
risks of meeting with North Korean
leaders without preconditions without
having them previously make sort of real
commitments to change I hope I'm wrong
that's my sort of final point on this
North Korea thing I hope that I'm wrong
and that we really do see the reforms
from North Korea that so many in the
West and and in South Korea and in Japan
and even in China have been hoping for
for decades at this point I've explained
clearly why
I remain skeptical but please the White
House should not be involved in the
production of North Korean style
propaganda discuss this with us on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
IDI vit luke vargas joins me from
singapore after the break the david
pakman show at david pakman.com welcome
back to the David Pakman show
Luke Vargas joins me today from
Singapore he's the chief foreign
correspondent for talk media news he
also hosts the weekly foreign policy
radio show and podcast wake with luke
vargas
he was he's not just vacationing in
singapore he actually has been there for
the trump kim jeong-hoon summit and
let's sort of start with the basics Luke
I mean talk about the setting talk about
the structure of the meetings what can
we glean sort of not so much from the
actual paper that was signed but from
body language and kind of like the
flavor of what's been going on there
well I've been here for a while and I'm
gonna be here longer than apparently I
need to be there was some talk among the
white house planners that everything was
ready for this to possibly go into a
second day and as we'll talk about later
the fact that the deal met that rapport
was strong the deal making was occurring
right even after the unike was signed
I'm not quite sure and I wish I could
have asked President Trump or someone
else why did it get this summit could
cut off where it got cut off but that's
a matter for another day this is the
perfect place in my view for a
high-stakes international summit
Singapore maybe like a country like Oman
which also plays one of these unique
sort of regional power brokering roles
has figured out most of its domestic
issues and kind of like a really good
friend and a stable relationship is just
there to help you out you know and and
they're eager to pick up the tab and and
you know handle the security for foreign
dignitaries and I have to say the this
is the safest city in the world
according to a number of different
studies
and I think in many ways that was
palpable just going to all these
conference events I mean there was
security and a big military presence but
I've had you know encountered more more
militaristic security approach to events
in New York City and I think a lot of
that has to do with the fact that
Singapore is so safe there's not a lot
of other sort of factors that could
really mess this whole sum it up the
summit itself not that interesting in
many ways it was not the in my view the
pomp and circumstance even of the DMZ
meeting between North Korea and South
Korea and April where you had all these
military honor guards and music and and
all these photo ops there are some of
that yesterday but not quite as much it
started with a 40-minute meeting face to
face some people were as freaking out
about this historians and journalists
because there was no one else in the
room other than the heads of state and
their translators I sort of saw this is
a good thing and these are two leaders
that and do need to get to know each
other and and if the goal here is to
avert you know a nuclear war then even
spending 40 minutes talking about cars
or New York City nightlife is better
than you know not having a chance just
to look into your adversaries eyes so
that's how it begins then relatively
boilerplate two and a half three hours
of bilateral meetings and culminating in
this signed agreement we'll get to that
one second and body language I think in
many ways Kim Jong Un's body language
was the one to watch I think we know how
President Trump comports himself I
thought Kim in many ways was mirroring
Trump at points he's a man who's shorter
and that's always been a concern to his
aides who wanted to make sure get
overpowered when standing next to Trump
I thought Kim did a great job sort of
matching his posture and gait if you
look at these photos of the two men
walking down these colonnades at the
hotel they are almost walking in
precisely unison with each other I think
that's Kim mirroring Trump not the other
way around and yet I also thought Kim in
many ways is cognizant that you know for
his propaganda film makers he wants to
give them two types of summits right he
wants to give them enough material that
looks like he's affable a genial man
who's willing to play nice with an
adversary but also subtle physical
gestures putting his hand on Trump's
back as he they walk out of a room that
if any point where the relationship goes
south
and he can say look you know I I you
know was walking this guy around and
leading him everywhere and some I
thought he was certainly very conscious
of the way he was appearing on cameras
yeah maybe some elements have shared
bonding over food I mean neither of them
is particularly trim and and that that
may have been something that that led to
the furthering of the possibility of
international peace negotiations but
let's get to the actual joint statement
that was put out right which my analysis
not to redo it all for you now but my
analysis was not unlike that that of
some others I thought that what most of
what was in the agreement the joint
statement was relatively unremarkable
mirroring commitments that have been
both vague and unenforceable from North
Korea in the past and I'm curious how
was the content of that statement
communicated to you guys to press that
were there terribly we were all stuck on
in buses about 200 or so journalists if
I didn't this is not just you know
people like me or even sort of younger
journalists it was network news anchors
and Hannity was on another bus I saw
Hertz from Fox News you know slumped
against a doe in a hot bus waiting in
traffic all of us were stuck in the
middle of Singapore traffic trying to
get to the press conference several
hours later and everyone's huddled
around cell phones trying to listen to
the signing statements and then trying
to figure out what had been signed I
mean the White House is spinning this
already everyone's talking about a
historic deal yet nobody knows what has
actually been signed and the White House
doesn't send anything officially until
three hours later which is an hour into
Trump's hour and five minute press
conference and so if I understand
correctly
Trump's doing the press conference he's
already well into the press conference
bragging about what was achieved but
that's the content of the statement that
they signed had not yet been
communicated to the press that's correct
I mean they're Bloomberg I believe was
the photography pool for the signing
statement and they had a telephoto lens
of course and zoomed in and one of their
reporters like they probably kept it
in-house for a minute and tried to
analyse it but then they sort of started
circulating snippets of it but I guess
it's always possible that something else
was signed or the formal agreement was
different than what was brought to the
table so we didn't really report on and
fully but yeah in
press conference you can hear Trump sort
of saying everyone's seen this and
reporters including myself started
shouting back no we haven't and finally
he gets the message and it sort of says
hey guys send it to them but they still
don't do it for another 25 minutes or
something it's back to the content of
the document it's really four paragraphs
at the end of the day the joke is that
these things called joint communique z'
of which this was a sort was a
communique to communicate that it really
didn't have much meat on it the four key
elements two of them I think we can just
toss out right away they're very vague
pledges to build a peace regime on the
Korean Peninsula to revitalize the
relationship and there's nothing wrong
with you can saying you're gonna
revitalize the relationship but one
would have expected something more a
date for exchanging ambassadors maybe a
pledge to create a special interest
section or interest section in Pyongyang
and maybe one in DC but again that's
very vague there is a nuclear line which
says that essentially there's no new
language here that they're going to
stick up for the pamela jeong
declaration which is from april that's
the document that was signed at the end
of the DMZ summit and that document also
if you go into that it's a little bit
longer than this but it also just talks
about phased disarmament and doesn't
have the new specifics and that was
purposeful that document was crafted
because there was an expectation that
when Trump and Kim met there'd be more
robust nuclear language that would
supersede it and of course that hasn't
happened and now the pennmen jean
declaration looks beefier than this and
the final point which having just read
the Korean Central News Agency North
Korean propaganda story about appears
like it was a spontaneous ask from Trump
which was relating to the POV he's
getting back the remains of people you
know Americans who died or were captured
in North Korea in the 1950s during the
Korean War and whose remains are still
there and seemingly on the spot
according to the Koreans that you know
Kim just acceded to this demand and that
was the fourth of the four paragraphs
but imagined this document which already
looks weak lacking that paragraph one
that Trump was talking up repeatedly
during the press conference there isn't
a lot of meat on the bone so let's talk
about the press conference you were in
the third row during the press
conference and there were a number of
sort of unusual elements during this
press conference once was that there was
this video that we would have assumed
was North Korean propaganda it was
actually produced by the White House and
we
talking about that on the program today
also there were references sort of
offhandedly to additional provisions
that Trump and Kim jong-un sort of
discussed verbally after the joint
statement was signed which of course
exists nowhere on paper and make this
entire thing even more bizarre in my
mind which is that it seems as though
the differences between this negotiation
and prior negotiations exist only
verbally and took place after the
signing of the document that was
published
yeah well that notion of a tossin is a
real estate term I mean you do these
once you sign something on paper then
the landlord is throwing in all sorts of
concessions and the the new you know
tenant is excited oh the landlord's
listening to my demands but conveniently
they're all you know verbal agreements
and you can never point to a lease and
say hey you know we we you said you were
gonna dismantle that nuclear site or you
know install the new washing machine so
yeah I mean there's a huge gulf between
the deal that's on paper and the deal
president Trump seems he you know think
about in his head let's talk first about
the video which startled all the
reporters there was no introduction to
this and it was a Korean first they
played it in Korean and then looped it
all back again so it's like a five
minute video played twice for us and we
did actually think it was a North Korean
you know multimedia material that was
brought and it had all all parts kind of
you've seen I at risk of just identify
identifying the Donald Trump offspring
is either Eric or Donald Trump jr. who
had a promotional video for a new like
shared work space living community and
Dumbo in Brooklyn and it looked a lot I
mean you know I would be so not
surprised if it was the same sort of
marketing team that did both of these
videos it has all this you know it's the
hallmark you know stock footage of a
basketball player with no uniform
dunking on a court on a parquet with no
logos on it either it's like and then
shots of the condos in South Beach this
was apparently a video Donald Trump
played to Kim and I was thinking like if
you're a US ally looks at Botswana who's
like doing most things right and but
could be better the economy is okay but
why not have a much more prosperous
economy are you gonna get any sort of
presentation from Trump like become our
friend and like we'll make make you the
country of your dreams no he's giving
this pitch to a guy who's you know a
murderous dictator that also seemed odd
and then we'll talk about the toxins I
mean so the biggest one of course is a
concession from the US which isn't
anywhere on paper and it's possible like
other things
Trump has demanded of the military that
they are going to wait for some more
formal order to in this case stop the
joint military exercises with South
Korea and maybe they'll never actually
get it certainly Trump's decision to
call these war games to say they aren't
necessary for American and Korean
security that they're too expensive that
Korea isn't footing enough of the bill
the Pentagon doesn't share those beliefs
and is operating on the assumption that
they work the military exercises are
going to continue the other Towson's our
concessions coming from North Korea
saying they're going to destroy a
missile facility of saying that they're
going to stop nuclear and ballistic
missile tests again that would be a
really nice thing to have in writing
because they have never agreed to that
formally before but Trump seems to thank
this again most important nuclear
related matters of this whole summit are
it's fine to just leave those as in sort
of informal handshake agreements and of
course there's an innocent explanation
here and a cynical one the innocent one
being look this is their very sensitive
issues they don't want to mess them up
they don't want to be premature and
putting language out there that both
sides might not agree to and there is
agreement on all sorts of fronts they're
just going to wait a few weeks to put it
on paper the much more cynical
explanation which I'm somewhat more
inclined to believe is that you know
take take out the pow2 man that Trump
apparently had the last minute which did
gets you know moved into the agreement
and there actually isn't anything these
guys are not the positions are not
converging despite all the recent
meetings and Trump goes up to the podium
saying shoot I didn't agree to anything
let me just sort of start talking about
some unicorn deal that doesn't exist
will it into existence and that's that
would be concerning of course Luke in
the limited time we have left
lack of nuclear knowledge seemed to be a
theme of the press conference that that
happen there in other words Trump talked
a lot hyperbolically about successes but
it didn't really seem as though he knew
much about sort of how so-called nuclear
works how disarmament would work or
really any of the logistics he didn't
and he also keep one of the details that
would be really nice to have is what is
this ballistic site are related to the
engine program of the ballistic missile
program in North Korea that they are
going to destroy because there's already
one called a hari it's the driver and
engine facility I think and and that's
already slated for destruction so if
that's what it is then this is a really
a nothing burger negotiation point he
agreed to destroy something that's
slated for destruction right the other
bits are this tweet sent from Air Force
one where Trump says now the nuclear
issue is off the table of course that
possible unless the nuclear threat is
removed or destroyed which it hasn't
been and this also notion from Trump
that you know and I think he said this
in the press conference that you know
once you start to even partially take
apart the nuclear program the threat the
rest sort of disfigure it solves itself
which is the opposite of what experts
say which is that even if you get rid of
all the material and all the launch
sites you still have in North Korea at
least a whole you know sort of rank and
file of thousands of nuclear scientists
who possess intimate knowledge of how to
get back to that nuclear threshold again
and unless you retrain them or give them
something else to do
they're a very potent political force in
North Korea and they also hold the keys
to restarting that program so what he
talks about nuclear weapons just signals
he doesn't really know what he's talking
about Luke we're gonna keep following it
question what has been the most
interesting or unique a food item you've
had while in Singapore gosh I haven't
been terribly adventurous I'm trying to
think there the Marriott hotel which
sponsored the journalists had buffets
every night and there were some odd sea
creature salads with without much
garnish that I largely stayed away from
but other than that it was sort of
american-style dining for the last few
days so now that I'm caught up on sleep
and all the diplomats have left town I
am gonna branch out and see the rest of
the city all right Luke Vargas chief
foreign correspondent for talk media
news uncie's
sea creature salads you heard it here
first that was one of the big
revelations from the summit in Singapore
Luke pleasure as always to be talking to
you
thanks David talk to you soon the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
remember when President Obama was still
president and the right would concoct
these FEMA camp
conspiracy theories and I don't even
really remember the exact details
because they were so ridiculous but it
went something like Obama's going to
build a Fema camp it's gonna be like a
concentration camp or an internment camp
he's gonna put people in it he will
declare martial law and suspend future
elections and effectively crown himself
president for life as sort of a plan to
become a dictator or something like that
obviously none of that stuff happened
but the Trump administration is now
actually building a camp to concentrate
the kids that are being picked up by
Border Patrol coming into the United
States across the us-mexico border the
Department of Health and Human Services
is checking out Fort Bliss in Texas as a
place where they might be able to on
this massive army base build a tent city
to hold up to 5,000 kids according to US
officials whatever you thought about
President Obama this plan from the Trump
administration is way closer to a
concentration camp or an internment camp
than anything that President Obama even
proposed to do
never mind actually did and meanwhile
the Trump administration continues this
completely immoral practice of
separating migrant children from their
parents so the child shelters that exist
are already overflowing and just out of
curiosity if you set up this tent city
and kids die there what happens will it
be pursued the way that it should be
pursued or will it be sort of like that
they were undocumented they weren't here
legally anyway and it'll get brushed
under the rug I think we know which way
it'll go and it's absolutely disgusting
now online
I see people already saying this is a
concentration camp
I don't know right I mean I don't know
whether that's the phrase that I would
use but it certainly is pretty close to
an internment camp and in a way it's
Alex Jones conspiracy about FEMA camps
coming true except they're military
camps not FEMA camps and they're under
President Trump not President Obama they
are actually building the
and they're doing it in a place that
regularly has temperatures over a
hundred degrees in the summer it's the
first half of June I looked today the
temperature at Fort Bliss was going to
be a high of 99 degrees and they are
building a tent city to house little
kids this is the dystopia that we were
warned about 5,000 children without
their parents in a camp in a illegally
I guess we'll call it legal limbo will
there be social workers if you're gonna
have 5,000 kids you probably should have
at least 150 social workers to
adequately care for these children are
they planning to have 150 social workers
at the camp unclear and what I want to
know is what will it take for people to
cross party lines and just say this
can't happen we can't allow this to
happen because your dollars are funding
this your tax dollars my tax dollars are
funding this and in the end it's
effectively an internment camp for
little kids yeah I wonder if they'll
draw the same sense of urgency or
contempt maybe as they did for the
Japanese internment camps which I think
you can draw an analogy to certainly
these children aren't American citizens
like many of the Japanese people were
yeah but it's just as urgent I mean when
you're talking about kids what does that
matter so much you know what's scary
about that there was wholesale
indifference to the japanese-american
internment camps so if we are actually
if we want to figure out will there be
an a demand for action and outrage here
if we look back at what the attitude was
during World War two and the
japanese-american internment calves
doesn't bode well for us doesn't bode
well for us at all these are kids who
are not free to go
the military is controlling the space
and this is the type of thing that any
reasonable human rights organization
would say you're violating people's
basic human rights full stock yeah just
as the Japanese were seen as enemies at
the time Hispanics are now and so people
won't really care so much even though
you're dealing with kids here the
rhetoric from the current administration
has authorized these kids in a way that
they are indeed seen not necessarily as
enemies
but I would agree people that don't
really deserve the exact same care that
we would give to Americans sometimes I
sit back and just kind of wish we could
have a normal president it was noticed
that Donald Trump took no notes during
his bizarre meeting with Kim jong-un in
Singapore and when he was asked about it
his explanation was he doesn't need
notes because he has one of the great
memories of all time if you want to talk
about delusions of grandeur and
narcissism it is this video clip of
Donald Trump take a look remember that
Donald Trump also said last week that he
didn't really have to do much
preparation for the summit and I guess
that ended up being true since I
predicted two months ago that North
Korea would agree to the same stuff they
always agree to and that they haven't
actually done but what I want to focus
on is Trump's claim that he has one of
the great memories of all time Trump's
memory is terrible right
Trump supposedly couldn't remember
anything about his entire affair and pay
off with stormy Daniels he couldn't
remember having repaid his lawyer
Michael Cohen a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in hush money and just
yesterday he literally couldn't remember
the name of the new Italian Prime
Minister that he met just days ago I
mean he couldn't remember the guys name
take a look I have a very good
relationship with Prime Minister Bobby I
have great relationship with the new man
who I like a lot as you know from Italy
he just won and you know we had very
good and frankly a really good with
Merkel really good pretty much with all
one of the great memories of our time
doesn't remember the name of that guy
the world leader from Italy that he met
three days ago
here's Trump forgetting that he had
mentioned John Cornyn 15 seconds earlier
and mentions him again and says oh I
didn't mention the guy this is from
February a big win we had Mitch Senate
Majority Whip John Cornyn John thank you
great job
House Majority Whip Steve Scalise again
Steve thank you sir mentions Cornyn
House Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
Kevin chair John Thune and House
Conference chair cathy McMorris Rogers
did they forget your name John I don't
know what's going on here
John Cornyn everybody knows they didn't
put his name up but that's okay it's the
first time that's ever happened that
will a judge that'll never happen again
in 15 seconds forgetting that he just
mentioned John Cornyn and then here's a
personal favorite of mine Donald Trump
who I guess forgot Rudy Giuliani's face
looks like wonders where Rudy Giuliani
is when he's sitting right in front of
them with that I want to introduce Rudy
Giuliani and who's gonna be working with
Jared Kushner and with Tom Bassett we're
also here and Rudy is very much of an
expert on cybersecurity but a very
important thing to him and to what he
does and maybe I'll ask Rudy to say a
few words well thank you thank you very
very much mr prevel congratulations on
what if in fact a historic start come on
guys
if trump's memory is so incredible why
did Rudy Giuliani actually say it's not
a good idea for him to speak to robert
muller because memory is malleable and
the truth is relative
if trump's memory is really so great sit
him down with robert muller and let's
get this thing over with what once and
for all
trump's like the kid who badgered others
for studying for a test in school or for
putting on their seat belt it's almost
like a point of pride that he doesn't
take notes
100% intelligent lucid brilliant people
take notes james comey for example comes
to mind whose notes are of particular
interest and this is just another one of
these attempts to appeal to the lowest
common denominator of intelligence it's
sort of like a faux superhuman thing
going on and it actually does influence
some of trumps followers who just eat
this stuff up hey man did you see Trump
you didn't even need to take notes for
that summit it is absolute and utter
nonsense we've got a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two
David P let's take a quick listen to a
voicemail this is a voicemail about hey
tree at mail take a listen hey David I
just wanted to say I think my favorite
thing about hatred mail is that the
people who are writing in are probably
the most likely people who would say
that you required to learn English to be
a part of this country yeah Georgie was
been you know yeah that's funny
so the patriot mail is is these dramatic
readings of hate mail that I get hatred
mail is known for horrible spelling and
grammar and politically it's the hatreds
who would insist that everybody must
learn English and speak English in the
United States and that other languages
aren't acceptable that is a an
interesting contrast with hatred mail
that never occurred to me before
voicemail caller didn't really finish
the point but I think we both picked up
on this yeah yeah yeah I understand what
they're saying for sure and it is a very
very good point about hatred mail and
unfortunately I wouldn't expect hatred
mail to become the the type of
incredibly well-crafted a narrative
prose that we might be used to if we
regularly read well-written fiction or
whatever we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today we will talk
about ranked choice voting in Maine
under threat we will talk about why I
hop has changed its name and why it
might work and we will also talk about a
European dispute which leads to
Macedonia getting a new name join
pakman.com and patreon.com slash david
pakman show both ways to get instant
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you